- J'arrive en retard les gars
- Comme d'habitude
- Alors comment ça va ?
- Tu vas bien ?
Philippe le décorateur
- Alors Philippe, comment tu vas ?
Et Johnny est très fier de son intérieur.
- On a fini pratiquement.
- Ah ba oui, c'est bien ce qu'il m'a fait à la maison.
- J'adore, j'adore.
Il y a beaucoup de choses qui ont changé.
Je n'avais pas vu moi la table.
La cheminée en croco là, alors ça,
j'avais jamais vu, bravo hein.
- Tu ne l'as pas chez toi ça ?
- Ah non j'ai pas, non non non non non
- Non, je ne vais pas faire la même
chose chez toi et chez Christian quand même.
- Mais Johnny est beaucoup plus
rock 'n roll que je le suis.
Le canapé il est de folie.
- Tu rigoles ou quoi ?
- C'est toi le rock'n roll
- Plus disjoncté que toi y a pas hein !
- Quand j'ai acheté la maison,
c'était une maison qui était un peu
un peu triste.
Ça me correspondait pas tout à fait
au point de vue décoration.
Et puis, j'en ai longuement discuté avec Philippe.
Et puis, on a complètement changé toute la décoration.
C'est à dire on a mis
On a mis sur les colonnes et sur les murs
on a mis du croco.
Petit à petit on a aménagé tout ça.
Et puis, ça a commencé à ressembler
un peu plus à ma personnalité
et puis à celle de Laetitia aussi.
Chic, en étant quand même un peu, le côté un peu rock'n roll quand même.
Pour moi, Los Angeles, c'est un petit peu
détente, vacances, et en même temps travail
parce que, comme je répète avec mes musiciens ici,
quand je fais des spectacles
et en même temps j'enregistre mes albums ici,.
donc je mélange les deux.
Et moi, ici, ça me permet d'avoir mes motos, mes voitures.
Pour moi, c'est l'idéal en tout cas.
Vous avez vu la cuisine ?
- La cuisine, je ne l'ai pas vue non plus.
- La petite Jade là.
- Qu'est-ce qu'elle est belle
Magnifico.
Alors ça, c'est de folie Johnny.
- J'adore ça ouais.
- J'adore, ça c'est vraiment un truc pour toi ça.
Le Fisher prize.
Elvis
Ah mais je n'avais pas vu celle là Johnny !
- Ah ba ouais
- Ça c'est une photo mythique pour moi.
Tu sais, elle l'est devenue aussi pour moi.
Ah c'est gentil tu l'as mise dans la cuisine.
- Bah ouais, je bouffe en face
de ta gueule tous les jours.
Et c'est parti pour une journée entre amis et en Hot Rod.
Les petits bolides au look années 30.
- Allez on prend le hot rod.
Le sien est prêt ou pas alors ?
- Bah le mien est en bas oui.
- T'as le tien ?
- Ah bah bien sûr
- Bon bah on va y aller alors
- Et le mien tu l'as vu ou pas ?
- Le tien oui, t'as encore mis ton nom dessus.
- Bah oui, comme ça, en cas que je me perde, ils savent où me ramener.